you
ladies and gentlemen listening to the hd
podcast you are listening to the h3
podcast after dark the premiere live
podcast on the what's going on is joe
rogan live now that he's on the whole
oh he's not even live he's a coward
that's awesome that's it we're the only
ones in the game with the guts to come
out here live and deliver his job
there's nobody doing what we do
there's nobody that does what we do
[Music]
what you know what you're looking like a
snack and a hat
i don't know so you got a baby in you
thank you you're welcome
you you look amazing
a whole buffet a snack xl
yeah when they make like snickers xl
it's like when you large the mcdonald's
order
yeah you want it normal size or large or
super sized
family size i'm a family size snickers
thanks hila that means a
lot um
damn though girl
enough to work on another baby real soon
after this
welcome everybody
welcome welcome it's age three after
dark it's the only live experience
you're gonna find at this high of a
level let's be honest this is we're the
only one the king of live
we'll do it live
king of all king of all media
well that's howard stern but i mean he's
on he's retiring soon i could take that
up and he's only on satellite
i haven't
am i really the king of all media i
haven't made a movie i haven't made a tv
show i haven't i don't paint i don't
write
you're coming for a spot i literally i'm
just i'll take king of live podcasts on
youtube on youtube at 12
on friday
it's still good still good
wow what a fantastic show we have
planned today
uh so much to talk about i just saw
james charles just uploaded a video too
so it's like gangbusters
he's like sisters everybody's just oh oh
we've got gabe where are you gabe
gabe what today what is today
a friday baby
no work no work on friday hell no well i
am working right now that which
contradicts that statement oh it's okay
gabe where when did you start
introducing the woos we love the woos it
was over there no we were doing cameos
and stuff and everybody you know i i
made up that whoo
and everybody everybody likes talking i
love the woo fluctuate that with my my
videos [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
you love that yeah it's like it's like
the one two punch that gets him and
knocks him out every time where are you
right now
oh i just got kicked out of the dmv for
waiting too long in line wait baby wait
you got kicked out of the dmv
wait how'd you get kicked out of the dmv
well
as well as waiting too long in line
[ __ ] it you kicked
and we're not we're not waiting in no
lines on friday it's friday baby no it's
friday baby yeah no dm it's the weekend
baby yeah yeah [ __ ] the dmv right [ __ ]
the dmv yeah oh yeah
hey gabe can we ask someone behind you
what they think about the dmv
well sure interesting yeah let's just
get your man on the street let's just
get some
hey what do you think of the dmv
uh dmv
i don't know it's a place where you have
to go to do things it sucks right yeah
baby
you heard it here folks everybody on the
street
yeah
all right gabe well listen i hope you
have a fantastic weekend i appreciate
you calling in and i [ __ ] do baby woo
[ __ ] yeah
yeah happy fourth fourth of july oh yeah
happy fourth of july
yeah oh wait is it a long weekend it's a
long weekend it's a long weekend baby
four days baby
[ __ ] yeah baby no week no squirt no
school no dmv [ __ ] no
are you gonna get ripped on some white
claw
maybe
it's the weekend
oh yeah it's the weekend [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby let's go all right gabe take
care we love you we'll see you on friday
all right see you next friday all right
take
care right all right
[Laughter]
dmv
that's good that's smart to multitask
yeah i mean you got to get stuff done
especially on a friday you don't want to
waste a single second
wow it's a long weekend does that mean i
don't have to work next week
yeah
i mean you're the boss do we have ads
next week dan
you want to take a week off i would love
to take a whole [ __ ] year off leave
me alone
leave me the [ __ ] alone
uh yeah i mean we only have um like
seven ads next week we do [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby
so um
james charles just posted a video being
like sisters uh people lied and said i
texted 20 miners in actuality it was
only 17 so
you know i am losing faith in this
society i swear to god bro somebody got
to clap down on these youtubers you got
james charles who are little predator
he's a predator i mean let's not miss
words
he is a predator and i won't surprise if
he goes to jail soon but here he's
posting a video called an open
conversation hi sisters where he's doing
a makeup tutorial you guys he's doing a
makeup tutorial while he's talking about
serious allegations of being a predator
yeah you guys can watch the evolution of
his uh
his glam
i do know that nothing says glamour more
careful and more patient moving forward
but i still want to be able to talk to
new people meet new people oh so oh
great he's not stopping
i just jumped i just jumped
i just jumped he's not stopping guys
have experiences just like every human
being does and find love like every
human being deserves oh my god
you can't meet new people
what we're telling you is you can't talk
with 16 year olds on snapchat what don't
you understand about that i want to do
but before that i do want to give
at 3 52 he starts this tutorial it's
pretty amazing
version of me there's oh 352 let's get
the moment where he decides
that it's time to put on makeup
let's get glam
so anyway i was talking to the fbi hold
on a second let's get glam
and i told him well i'm gonna have to
talk to my lawyer
hold on let me get my new brush so
embarrassing sad i think we should just
go ahead and get started all right you
guys so i'm just gonna get started on my
makeup routine this is definitely not
going to be a tutorial like i said
the conversation throughout guys this
can't be real this can't be real i can't
refuse to believe this so it's like
it's like i wonder if it's going to
start branding his looks because you
have like my everyday makeup routine um
so this is like my apology my makeup
open conversation routine i think we got
to change the title to james charles
you got to throw it in there it's what
do people want that is so true bro why
do i live in a world where i get more
dislikes on my video and i have never
attempted to solicit sex from a minor
or fans even
why do we live in a world where i get
more dislikes than james charles ela why
do we need inspiration
why do we live in a world
where people like austin mcbroom of ace
family is literally scamming people rice
gum is still popular he's participating
in crypto scams
and people think that's cool and i'm out
here getting more dislikes than all of
them
i don't know why am i getting disliked
what did i do i didn't scam anyone i
didn't try to flirt with 16 year olds
but [ __ ] your sons
that's not my sister sense
and i'm the one getting sued for by
trailer
what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ]
you know sometimes he gets real amped up
[ __ ] baby doesn't make any sense
oh he wrote a little message here i
think it's just like
i i don't know people just don't care if
someone is a douchebag i guess they're
criminals now they're not just your
heartbeat like that's what i say about
myself
i don't know why it's okay
i'm okay now with people liking
douchebags
it's like bryce hall's a douchebag it's
like cool enjoy it but like these these
are criminals now yeah and not only
criminals like people like rice gum and
all these space guys we'll talk about
all these phase guys got kicked out of
phase and uh for scamming their fans
all right and i'm the [ __ ]
can we change the title on a live show
dan yeah let's do james charles let's
change the thumbnail too
nobody cares about the baby
and to be honest
and he's still got the bird nest haircut
of all the things that he got
criticizing he's still going to step in
front of the camera with the [ __ ]
bird nest where's the eggs james that's
so true
look at this [ __ ]
and i'm the one getting dislikes and
he's going out there with that
okay all right cool
here he's got a message here
is long time no see
i've been in custody with the fbi and
i've just been released on bail
after a lot of self-reflection and many
conversations with friends i came up
with some cool fbi looks that i can't
wait to share with you
this is my incarceration look it looks
great in orange
this is awesome
the internet is so the internet is so
truly [ __ ]
youtube is such a wasteland
and i'm the [ __ ] imagine that
that's something that i can't
turn off okay here he says i've come to
terms with several issues oh wait he
goes i've had many conversations with
friends family role models
lawyers
he says professionals he means lawyers
industry professionals lawyers
therapists federal agents
i've come to terms with several issues
i've been ignoring for a long time now
in today's video i wanted to be of an
honest conversation oh i feel like my
accent's falling apart yes
in today's video i wanted to have an
honest conversation and hope to answer
some questions
share my progress and talk about what
i've been up to over the past couple of
months
with anyone who wants to listen let's
get glam
i wouldn't date the absolute youngest
this is a predator
on youtube what do you want me to title
this
um an open conversa here what's a good
like play on words on that
james charles
james charles says he's never stopped it
and you can't do anything about it
fbi watch james charles new video
watch us with the fbi at james charles
new video you guys got any ideas
james charles in sincere apology
tutorial is it an apology
um
james charles oh
i'm actually go ahead
do you still have his video up yeah hit
right
hit refresh
no i don't want to refresh because i'm
gonna how did he delete it already i
mean i don't know
people are saying that that's what
they're saying wait i'm afraid to
refresh it because then i won't be able
to watch it i someone's got to download
it right maybe i'm i'm going to try to
rip it and then wait i don't i don't
want to refresh it
oh people are saying you didn't what's
wrong with the chat oh people are
goofing us i'm sorry well one of you
told me if you deleted it so i don't
know if they [ __ ] up my cat they lied to
you
they lied wow that was good they're
still there what the hell okay chat can
you explain yourself they're just
they're trolling had you all come up
with that so fast yeah
okay well anyway
this is you know
okay
[Music]
and the support is amazing man i don't
get this support and i don't even pray
on kids that's crazy
i feel so bad for james imagine how bad
his trust issues are now bro i feel so
bad for james so embarrassing
i feel so bad for james
i'll be sticking around james i love you
thank you for always being transparent
wish you nothing but the best and you
will find your person one day i did i'm
32 and i'm happy people are [ __ ] 32
year old watching this [ __ ] are you
kidding me
that's a good point
bro this shit's unbelievable this guy's
a predator
and he's out here on youtube getting all
flex like 100 percent like ratio chuck
garlic ratio it ain't that high
the [ __ ] that i do except be a douche
i'm a dick okay fine what the [ __ ] did i
do i didn't commit any crimes didn't
hurt anybody
why don't you take a seat right over
there exactly
yo what's the title apparently he
deleted the old one that oh
taking accountability
what a [ __ ] douche
so no
okay so now he's rewriting history he er
he erased the accountability one where
he's like yes i did send a bunch of
other stores
and he's replaced it
he's replaced it with
i didn't do anything wrong and i'm gonna
keep doing it
yeah love that about him uh it's gross
my sisters james charles
james charles rewriting history
do we like that i mean i'm six minutes
still debating this title
so far he's reiterating the same points
he did in his initial apology so okay so
wait this here
do you think as creators or not even
really creators as human beings we
should also be able to defend ourselves
on things that we didn't do now when i
posted my last video holding myself
accountable i mentioned that i was going
to be taking a break from social media
for a while and wouldn't be responding
to anything and quite a lot of people
took advantage of my time away and
really ran wild with all sorts of
stories and
that's not true this all came out before
he bailed i haven't talked about it
since he bailed
or not like continued to
dude he's rewriting history well the fbi
knows what happened they've got your old
video downloaded don't worry
videos and allegations that made this
situation a lot worse i do want to take
some time in this videos today to just
shed some light and further information
on some stories you know that either did
or did not happen and you're not going
to do makeup where you're doing social
media while i was gone because i think
it's really important that you guys have
the full picture of what actually went
down there was basically one drama
channel on twitter that started a thread
and started compiling a list of anybody
that said literally anything about me on
social media and after what felt like
weeks of somebody knew coming forward
every single day hold on we
vetted i don't think he's talking about
you no i know but i'm saying he's making
it sound like this person was just all
these people were just making [ __ ] up
because we vetted
and we as far we as accurately as
possible concluded that it was like 17
people that actually received
right these were all written in articles
yeah this is this this this is just a
[ __ ] lie
wow sister snapped but like he's he's
creating a little space
where it's like yes there were some
reports there that were not true
and there was a lot that were true
so he's like trying to rewrite history
like some of them were true and casting
doubt on all of them but let's be frank
those many of those are real the
majorities are real it eventually became
the 20 victims of james charles okay so
it was 17.
you know
right i'm gonna go through this list one
by one because i know that nobody wants
to stay here for an hour listening to me
talk about this but i do feel so i have
to say something because i am just not
comfortable with this video or really
any video moving forward allowing
anybody let alone my followers to think
that there are any victims of james
charles let alone 20. you [ __ ] just
deleted a video of you saying you
sent bro what the [ __ ]
this is oh this is dude youtube is such
a
[ __ ] irredeemable cesspool
[ __ ] this
i [ __ ] hate this i'm sorry but this
is just
people get away with
crying the worst crowd i can't believe
what i'm seeing
i'm so pissed off you know it's a
culmination of this with the rice gum
all the crypto scamming that's been
going on with faze and all these [ __ ]
and then on twitch people are doing
gambling now they're being paid millions
of dollars i learned about this on
twitch then the like most popular meta
right now is just playing slot machines
and the slot companies are paying these
twitch streamers millions and millions
and millions of dollars it's like
everything is such a cess [ __ ] pool
right now that makes sense sick thank
you wendy
[Laughter]
and on top of that i got a free brittany
and then i'm i'm the one being sued by
ryan cavanaugh who's allegedly runs a
ponzi scheme according to his ex-partner
and i wouldn't be posting on social
media like nothing ever happened but
this has been the worst but most
important wake-up call of my entire life
for a lot of different reasons and this
is by far the most embarrassing thing to
ever happen to me embarrassing
how it's embarrassing if it didn't
happen
embarrassing what the [ __ ] are we
talking about here
i don't know this is beyond embarrassing
james
i'm
i don't have to say about this
so no cookies for you
i'm blown away by this i didn't prepare
to talk about this so yeah it's like a
30 minute video here but like
there's a 30 we've read a comment from a
30 something year old woman who supports
him and that's the world we live in
i mean if you guys been following for a
while now you all know what happened in
2019 i'm definitely not going to get
into that but you know when that all
happened i was accused of something that
i did not do and i was able to prove it
all okay what about now but i did
recognize that i needed to make changes
and i uploaded a video making a lot of
promises to my audience shut the [ __ ] up
that sucks so much it's not pretty
confident
so
horrifying and embarrassing but at the
end of the day it's my own fault and my
own responsibility to you know take
accountability for what i did i want
he's mate doing makeup on his ear though
he's gonna ask he's he's makeup being
the back of his ear
much is not even funny and it's so
horrifying and embarrassing but at the
end of the day it's my own fault and my
own responsibility to you know take
accountability for what i did i want to
be held accountable for what i did do
you
know
bro i can't i swear yeah that's so upset
i think maybe just move on
really i mean it's friday baby
[Music]
friday
on social media and we can take a vote i
mean i'll give the people what they want
you guys want the friday show or you
want the james charles
ethan cline breakdown meltdown
set up a scrap ball i'll do whatever the
people want i'm here to please got that
forward every single day it eventually
became the 20 victims of james charles i
am not going to go through this list one
by one because i know that nobody wants
to stay here for an hour listen i'm not
going to go by these lists one-on-one
because i know i've already done with
the fbi and my lawyers and federal
agents
yeah of course you're not gonna go buy
them one by one because the majority of
them are real you [ __ ]
i think we talk about this but i do feel
so i have to say something because i am
just not comfortable with this video or
really any video moving forward allowing
anybody let alone my followers to think
that there are any victims of james
charles let alone 20 victims of james
charles because that is completely
unequivocably not unequivocal now when i
say that literally anything and
everything was being added to this list
i really do mean anything and ever are
we working on a poll
yeah
no they're working on it
there were a few different influencers
from tiktok that studied some ideas or i
slid into their dms and had a five
minute conversation with them until
asking their age or sexuality and then
completely stop responding there are
guys that i met with on tinder last year
and they had their ages set to 18 or 19
so i talked to them and flirted with
them for a while because that's the
whole point of an adult dating app until
i realized bro why is he acting like
they're not dms of people saying their
age and he continues the conversation
or also that he was supposed to already
learn his lesson from the previous time
yeah and not just take people's word for
whatever you can't just [ __ ] go and
then oh add me on snapchat mr emmy on
snapchat what the [ __ ] that about
james you sick freak i'll just be your
secret lover
sick dude
do you guys hear that uh chris hanson
got a search warrant for him by the way
weird
chris everybody's [ __ ]
chris
i'm afraid the uh
early poll results oh there are no james
all right [ __ ] it
good call everyone
by the way pretty overwhelming margin
actually well [ __ ] james charles it is
friday baby
i mean the thing is there's not there's
nothing new to say about it
you're just going to repeat everything
we've already said i'm going to drop a
dislike on it
and i call it autumn i'm going to drop a
comment from dan no not about my account
all right
what does it matter i'll say ethan this
is ethan not dan
i guess whatever okay
hi james
[Music]
seriously dude
come on
like
seriously
i really gotta sit through 30 minutes of
you to try and pretend
like you aren't a predator
come on okay
allegedly
right my name is dance no no you gotta
write allegedly if it's on my account
i'm collecting yeah i'm not gonna put it
all right [ __ ]
[ __ ] that really pissed me off dude all
right
please it's the amount of support he
gets no serious topics today
okay hey it's friday baby i'm gonna try
to redirect the pregnant lady here's the
baby she wants the baby
here's the baby oh there's the baby
[Music]
how do you want
so i got this app that tells me how far
i am and so right now it's the size of
an olive
oh that's cute
oh you know what that's even crazier
coincidence because no i shouldn't say
yeah okay
you stopped me real fast
so this is the little baby here
this is a little dome yeah
and a little body yeah
there's a little arm a little arm right
here and then the other slippers yeah
i'm really cool cord that this there
yeah
it's a little bit
for him to
lay down in and he says good night mommy
[Music]
that's our baby update
that's the baby update wait how many
weeks are you now
[Music]
um getting close to 10 weeks
damn
yeah due date is in february yeah
that's gonna come so fast i can't
believe you're pregnant it's so weird i
can move another baby
me too
it's going to be insane to have another
kid
by my life
um
so that's the baby update that's it
that's all we got oh
yeah there's not really much to say but
it's going really good the pregnancy is
going great ila is doing really good not
feeling sick
gaining weight eating looking beautiful
everything's coming together we're doing
feeling good doing good i'm super tired
very tired that's the only thing yeah
interestingly one of the biggest side
effects of being pregnant is just
getting
brutally tired yeah
we don't hang out anymore because the
minute you get home you just fall asleep
yeah not the minute i get home well
usually i always there to sleep and
walk the dogs
excuse me we take turns we take turns
but i'm just saying
i don't just come home and crash
okay come on i'm not trying to criticize
you i'm just making a point
um
you want to watch uh yeah it's
it's tough getting used to this because
i always plan on doing so much after
theodore goes to sleep because that's
usually like
the the peace time the quiet time the
peace and love time yeah
but now it's like i just fall asleep so
i don't get to do anything
yeah it's a lot it's intense man we
usually watch shows we even we're not
even caught up on love island or
anything
okay so this is not the harp on the
treasure drama because i'm over it but i
don't want to deprive the excellent work
of this fupa trooper from the subreddit
emergency gloomy put together a moving
infograph
of the live responses on a daily basis
regarding the frenemies breakup this is
pretty interesting i mean i'm just i'm
impressed with the work
you know she's accused me of dragging it
on
is that real
200
it takes that five percent
pretty amazing
you have five percent of the amount of
posts i know by the look of it yeah five
percent differences astronomical
actually i didn't realize it was not
much
i guess i didn't follow a lot of it
because it was a lot of tweets and tick
tocks and stuff
that's that's great man
she probably yeah she did good with all
that i mean she probably
lots of mid rolls and
five percent crater fund
all right so let's move it on you know
the african baby story we talked about
recently where this woman in africa
broke the world record
she made it up
not real
well what's this photo then what's the
point of making that up
first of all what is this photo we did
express a lot of skepticals and when we
talked i knew it she wanted the ten baby
club which one yeah
yo but is this her what is the actual
scoop on this photo now it's fake
there's a giant beach ball under there
or something she wasn't even pregnant i
need that clothes i have trying to find
what is in this lady's dress i cannot
find but it does look just like a beach
ball just a pillow because i know i've
never seen a woman pregnant looking like
that but i was like okay ten babies yeah
exactly like her boobs are not even but
yeah you know it's present it does look
fake where are the boobs yeah because
the boobs
they would be resting on top right and
the stomach would be like lower
it would be way lower oh this is so fat
how do we fall for this right because
the boobies are like under the belly
though oh who would they don't
lie about that yo those droopers those
boobs are about to feed 10 babies they'd
be all over the place bro
they would be like there'd be like a
boob here it'd be like damn
with her boob coming out
anyway okay so so
uh the bbc news did a full investigation
on this no hospital in the province have
recorded
uh
god this name for ten babies is de
souplets
the suplets
medical tests show that mrs [ __ ]
excuse me what
well her name is sit hole
her name is mrs sithole okay get your
word straight swear to god s-i-t-h-o-l-e
sit-hole
well if you save fast and just kind of
skip over the age
mrs schill
has not even been pregnant
the 37 year old is now being held at a
mental health
facility apparently oh what they're like
listen lady
that's not that [ __ ] that's all the info
i've gotta miss the [ __ ]
don't
that's your name
not a good joke
how is that not a good joke it's [ __ ]
amazing like what like racism
exactly
listen
okay i'm not gonna i'm not gonna argue
the point you're right i apologize mrs
sit hole where is that paul
i apologize to mrs sithole apology
podium and by the way i think it's i
think it's deck toplets or deck gupplets
deck like deca like tan desi
yeah
xxs ten
what does that have to do with exactly
okay so and then the other thing this is
fun this is really fun
you guys all saw our
big moment with stephen crowder yeah the
big debate i thought ethan was a
stand-up guy it was a huge story
especially in the political world so
there's this guy tim poole
who was a right-wing commentator yeah
who got so heated up by the way is the
thing we've prepared ready
uh yes okay good
uh he got so heated up about this
you gotta see this he's so angry at me
he's so angry allowed that
um
and it's just too funny not to watch so
this is tim paul
addressing me
uh with the with the debate and the
content he makes
is
drama pop culture like i said
and when he weighs into political spaces
it is actually very damaging to our
discourse not saying that he's not
allowed to i'm not saying that uh he
should stop i'm just saying it does
cause damage same is true for me or
anybody else however there's political
ideology
no dude the wreath
the wreath coming off this i i just find
that
it's so i could you be any more cry baby
so he had like a whole he had like a
whole thing where he was melting down
over sam cedar we just cut it out and
when he's specifically talking about me
but it's just so funny that they talk
about cancel culture and wreaths and
snowflakes this [ __ ] is the most
sensitive man i have ever met
this the wreaths coming off him are
radiating
the research behind the things that i
say the things stephen crowder says and
even the things sam cedar says i think
it's very obvious that if we're trying
to have really serious discussions about
the cdc
and you want to exploit that for
personal gain i'm going to call you
a bad person
okay
i wanted the debate
i wanted the debate
i said i don't have i'm not equipped for
this debate let's get two guys together
that are
and he bitched out so how am i a bad
person tim well
and what he needs to be implying
and and all of these all the commentary
that i've seen on it they all seem
they're either lying or they're under
the false impression that you set this
up that you challenged him to a debate
stephen crowder asked for the debate
like he's the one who invited you to
come debate he's the one that wanted to
find it comfortable
they like it they like that idea better
so they're just going to stick with that
right it happened because of
crowder he made it happen
he wanted to debate the pop culture
drama channel
and i said let's [ __ ] do it
and the result is you know and the res
the rest is history but how the [ __ ] is
this my fault you don't have to think
about it dude exactly
he's like we're having serious debates
like for example that that taking the
covet shot makes you turn into magneto
these are well researched high level
ideas these are high level ideas
for example
for example did you see when steven
crowder pretended to uh mock su die like
george floyd these are high level ideas
these are well researched facts and
you're destroying the space
take your stupid garbage games somewhere
else and get out of my face i'll take
them wherever the [ __ ] i want tim pool
and the fact that you're so pissed off
made me think that i hit the bullseye
get out of my face i mean sorry that it
blew up on the internet and it went all
over your face you're putting it in your
face
you just x the video i don't even know
what the [ __ ] you are signing off for a
few days i do know who he is i'm lying
this is the real baby update he sounds
like he's about to cry
he looks like a baby too let's see that
dome
dude wears a beanie like you remember
that uh there's all these memes of it we
were winning no i know but like he's
he'd never take something you've never
ever seen like he's in like dead
like he'll be out in like you know
112 degrees las vegas and he's got the
beanie on he's going to be fair you do
that too okay but i haven't i have to
point it out before someone else does it
comes on it comes off okay it's over
here it's over here okay anyway temples
i appreciate that you're right
you're right
somebody uh donated a hundred dollars
said with peace and love tim pool is the
only person i wouldn't want to see
wearing a teddy fresh beanie thank you
thank you for the thank you for that and
uh i'll use your 100 dollars to
uh
not send you my beanie
yeah pocket that [ __ ] it's free i'll
just pocket it thanks guys we'll get
some food i'm hungry bro
mexican
[Laughter]
so um
tim you guys remember that uh there's
like that
fable or fairy tale about the woman with
the red ribbon and if she took it off
her head fell off
oh yeah i don't which one that's temple
[Music]
[Applause]
that's tim right now
get the [ __ ] out of my face
ethan you want to come into the
political space and burn it all down
around you
you're such a drama queen where you're
saying that we have the power to burn it
all down i i mean that kind of sounds
like i even literally set up a debate
for them to discuss it so because i
don't know what i'm doing
how am i if anyone's burning it it's
stephen crowder who's turning it into a
circus inviting me to debate it
he should he should have been happy that
somebody showed up with those the topics
yeah i mean it in the in the full clip
because again it was like 30 minutes
long and the vast majority of it is him
getting even more mad than this about
sam
because he really [ __ ] hates sam
and the i i suspect the reason is he
actually did a debate with sam at one
point and he destroyed him it did not
pull that up i want to show you thanos i
got to see the thanos okay because so
there's a real i know some of you guys
don't care about politics but i promise
this is all funny
um they had a debate
and they were just talking about some
like i'm you i'm you uh utilitarian and
i'm but utilitarian and then tim was
like no i'm this other thing and he's
like i hate to say this to you sam but
you're just like thanos you're you're
philosophy is just like thanos and tim's
and sam was like i don't care
well he didn't know who that was because
he doesn't watch he's a 50 year old man
who doesn't watch marvel movies he just
looked tim just looks so dumb
and uh i think he's just mad because it
went viral and that's why you may have
seen sam with like thanos memes and
stuff
yeah someone sent me that clip i gotta
watch that before we gotta find it i
promise i know this is politics but i
promise it's fun i'm here just to burn
it all down i'm not
i'm not here to just talk about uh
not talk about the issues never about
the issues
only about the burning down
how is he gonna even make these
arguments if crowder really wanted to
debate it could have just debated
that's okay tim obviously thinks that
sam is a is a is a worthy person to talk
to he did himself he did talk to him
himself so all down around you okay fine
i can commend you for your talent and
ability in doing so and then i will say
you're a bad person and that
okay is your dad gonna call our dad too
it's just a fact
i think it's a nap time for baby
tim need some milkies
tim come here little baby i got your
milkies
mommy
mommy
mommy
mommy
tim full right now
milk is mommy
eater is a lot you guys got that thanos
clip we're looking for it i found
i found the debate we're looking for the
time stamp right now
all right let's keep it moving oh
shredder hey shred
i thought you were kicking me hilo like
move on
and that's why oh wow he really turned
up wait i want to miss this he's like he
looks how he turns up
listen how he turns up on me
i think so and then i will say you're a
bad person okay and that's just a fact
and that's why people like stephen
crowder should not debate him and that's
why stephen was right for cutting him
off and saying no
and ethan klein is is
damaging everything making it all worse
because his interest is personal gain
for his pop culture crap he doesn't know
what he's talking about so he would
rather watch people suffer if it gives
him a few extra bucks that's ethan klein
what the [ __ ] did i do
juice box mommy
he's getting cranky he doesn't need his
mouth timmy needs a nap he's very mad
ethan's ruining everything even klein is
is damaging everything making it all
worse
mommy
cancel ethan he's a bad person that's a
fact
okay we got the thanos clip
all right here it is this is why tim
hates sam by the way
yeah would you vote in favor of someone
that you could be sure was going to
create 10 concentration camps
this is the high level debate by the way
i would vote for someone who created
three concentration camps over 10
concentration camps really pushing the
needle with these [ __ ] high level
debates tim uh or would you vote or
would you would you vote for someone who
would create five concentration camps
would you not vote and not vote i would
vote for someone who is going to create
less concentration camps so your your
willingness to put your weight behind
somebody who's going to make
concentration camps no i'm not willing
to put i'm willing to put my weight
behind i'm sorry it's the next one under
it
oh
oh it's not this one yes i want it in
there
yeah so so for instance like thanos yeah
was the was utility military and captain
america was deontological
i didn't so thanos willing to reduce the
suffering by killing you know hundreds
of trillions versus the you know
thousands of trillions which would be
living better off so uh or or uh uh
yeah so
that's like thanos was the was
diminishing the number of concentration
camps
before you go that's a really great
point that i think may separate its
utilitarianism versus deontologism that
you you're quantifying versus i'm not
you see that i'm not saying you're wrong
i'm saying your philosophical standard
is the minimization of harm and mine is
more about the individual is the small
you know what i mean like yeah i'm
curious about the second part of that
you said you know what i mean because i
really don't know
the two philosophies about
feeling
violating the ethics of an individual is
violating ethics regardless
and yours is minimization of harm is
better so utilitarian versus
deontological from my standpoint
committing one ethical act is a
violation of principle and ethics that
can't be crossed but i will admit
there's not like a hard line because
um
i think that is silly
to be honest with you
i mean i i respect you you know but
they're very strong philosophical uh
positions
i
i believe that
less suffering is better and that i am
willing to i'll i will tell you
something you won't like to hear though
i'm willing to shuffle myself if that
that's the outcome but i'll tell you
something you're not going to want to
hear and and i admit it's it's uh i'll
call it dickish uh utilitarianism is
typically the villain yeah you guys
gotta find the whole thing you gotta
watch your poster
oh it was there he said i don't care
wait listen
oh this is a mess but it's right here
can you guys just are you still looking
and i admit it's it's uh i'll call it
dickish uh utilitarianism is typically
the villain in most movies
i don't care
i don't care
and so this clip went really viral of
tim poole trying to talk about thanos
and i think that's why he's so mad
i don't care
yeah which is the exact it's like why
are you using that as an actual argument
and then debate that thanos
thanos apparently is that was great by
the way just this little snippet yeah
because he's he like he's a dick these
people fall apart when they actually
are met with someone who really knows
what
[Music]
watch people suffer if it gives them a
few extra bucks that's ethan klein okay
you know it's fine ethan do your pop
culture comedy stuff it's funny stuff i
got no issue with that but don't come
into this space where people are trying
to have very serious conversations about
how people live and how people might die
if we don't solve certain problems
and kick the can down the road are you
it sounds like the perfect place
yeah it sounds like the perfect place to
come kick this [ __ ] around a little bit
man you are so this guy has great
visions of grandeur
he thinks so highly of himself
he's like we gotta save people's lives
by trying to get them not to take a
vaccine
that's how i save lives
or just make everything worse
you bring in a con a con man like sam
cedar whose whole business is just
burning things down for personal gain
and i'm gonna get pissed off something
he said about me this guy is a
manipulative lying con man
that's why crowder doesn't want to do
anything have anything to do with him
that's why all the people crowd are
mentioned don't want to have anything to
do with him and that's why i know this
picks for joe rogan and uh all the
people that he mentioned oh yeah he
speaks for joe rogan and yeah and uh oh
my favorite was noam chomsky
he speaks for noam chomsky
sam cedar makes all these videos and he
focus on drama i mean the man's
obsession with dave rubin is laughable
it's absolutely laughable
i hate saying his name
because it gives him attention the dudes
gained around 30 000 or so subscribers
after ethan propped him up so
congratulations that's why he's mad
it's because his channel is growing you
all got to better go subscribe to sam
cedar right now
i tell him thanos sent him thanos denim
temple thanos is
um
tell tim pool guys
that sam cedar has just collected
another infinity stone
[Laughter]
then on just not caring about the world
and being a self-interested you know
whatever when ethan steps in and just
throws a flaming bag of turret you know
flaming turd bag right in the middle of
the room i'm sorry
[Laughter]
sam does not deserve anybody's attention
oh hold on can we just take a moment to
reflect on the smash the like button uh
graphic that he's got there
about that
sam does not deserve anybody's attention
smash that like and it's a shame that i
have to say his name and give him
attention so what so you so you know
what if you like the guy go ahead and
follow him whatever if you want to
follow him then there you go he deserves
it but i think wait but you're not
making any sense he does uh tim you're
such a div [ __ ] who's engaged in
rational political conversation should
ignore this well anyway
oh what is this there's another tim paul
gets owned on joe rogan no it's just
that he said that he's single because of
feminism oh that was a [ __ ] great
tempo by the way
he went on joe rogan and he said
mega star who predicted 50-state trump
victory he went out and he said i'm
predicting a landslide all 50 states
including california for trump
the second time yeah bag of turkey or
flaming turd bag
i don't think his that that quote about
him being single because of feminism was
on joe rogan though i think that
screenshot is from joe okay wait can we
find that since we're talking about him
he's single because of feminism he says
uh i remember this i'm glad we have
opportunity to talk about it because
it's it's so [ __ ]
bro it's like really bad
i can't possibly have babies because of
climate change
say what
i can't possibly
it's got to be here somewhere right all
right one of you guys find it damn it
in the meanwhile
in the meanwhile
tim poole says i'm ruining everything
right
so we've prepared a little sketch
of of
what
it's not a sketch really happened what
are you talking about
so this is me tim full said i ruined
everything well we wanted to give you a
little behind the scenes
video to prove that he's wrong that i
don't ruin everything and that i am help
everybody so let's prove to him wrong
right now ethan yeah what you're doing
let me help you with the lights no
what the [ __ ] man
again
again i was just trying to help bro no
set's on fire
bro just i don't i don't need any help i
don't need any help okay i'm sorry i'm
gonna help
ah you don't have to watch that let me
take
don't
i think i actually got injured
ah
is there an injury there no
walk it off something impaled me so bad
dude
why didn't you stop me i i said it
wasn't done
[ __ ] we need a [ __ ] medic god damn it
medic
medic
guys i'm running low on battery can
someone help me to the charging dog
i got you dude here
how does this work it just goes back
here and just hold on
here no no no i got it okay
you're done i got it i got it i got it i
got it brian help me help me down have
it smell the phone put me down stop it
i got what i can dock you i know how to
talk to you
what are you doing this is not time you
do it wait i got it done
i got it you just here just walk right
into that yeah just park me
oh my god you're just making this worse
here you you need to learn to do this
yourself no you're you're making it
mercy though you are in you just missed
the spot
dad he's doing it
i'm just ruining everything serious
dude
i got it i got it ethan klein is is
damaging everything making it all
of here get on worse
get out what's the [ __ ] get out moving
here get the [ __ ] out what are you doing
go
coming down
get the [ __ ] out
you [ __ ] break the gatsby too the god
speech doesn't work
yeah bye
bye loser
yeah thanks for dropping by and [ __ ]
everything up
[Applause]
how did he know
[Laughter]
triggered tim poole really
yeah bag of turret you know flaming turd
bag
yo you guys gotta find this guy i didn't
know that tim pool is like such good
material oh bro there's there's a whole
twitter account
that's fairly popular that's just
dedicated to lampooning temple it's
pretty i mean if you guys bring back
content court
temple content court yeah i mean i'm
sure there's plenty
i'm sorry i'm gonna get pissed off about
that
yeah i'm sure you would yeah
and now i just want to promote sam cedar
as much as possible
the majority report you guys you come on
you got you did you find it
okay if you okay
tell me when you got it
yeah he says that he can't find a
girlfriend because of
uh
because of but like the specific reasons
he states is just it's kind of the best
thing ever
so
bag of tur you know flaming turd bag
oh man now speaking of the world just
falling apart around us bill cosby got
freed did you hear that yes
yeah there's a pretty good joke about
them
people ask for free
people ask for free brittany and the
universe freed bill cosby
yeah hey
okay
you found it dan
yeah great
this is fantastic
so here's why tim's full single and has
nothing to do with uh anything we just
talked about
that he's an emotion he's like uh uh
an unhinged
little weasel
i can't possibly have babies because of
climate change
right which is nonsense no but i do
think it's crazy that i'm about to be 34
and i have no family because my my dad
had two kids by the time he was 27 yeah
and i'm like man
you know what you know the problem is
though
it's definitely not me
i think it's
everybody else
i can't imagine actually saying that oh
my god imagine actually saying that
it's like it's
it's like a joke that it's like a sketch
it's like michael scott
yeah it's definitely not me it's
everybody else
oh my god it's almost like he he
diagnosed the problem
as he was saying it
then i'm about to be 34 and i have no
family
because my that's kind of sad but a
great sound bite
i'm about to be 34 and i have no family
so how do you explain i got a [ __ ] i
have a kid and a wife how do you explain
that one tim paul good luck explaining
that one you're ruining everything ethan
that's why the world's unfair it's
everybody else yes such in-cell vibes
from tim paul my dad had two kids by the
time he was 27 yeah and i'm like man
you know what you know what i did he
probably didn't walk around telling the
world that the problem is not him it's
the world
your dad probably didn't do that
yeah there's like there's like probably
like close to four billion women in the
world tim
it's all their fault it's all them
you know flaming turd bag the problem is
though
it's definitely not me no i think it's
everybody else how is this guy real
you know who has kids in a family
sam cedar i mean how do you
have this words come out of your mouth
and not laugh
and not laugh or immediately as soon as
you walk off the set you walk into a
therapist
yeah i just don't know go you know what
you go
oh
did i just say that
i'm going to end the show
[Laughter]
i wonder what her reaction was
she's like she's like yeah
everybody else i'd had two kids by the
time i was 27.
and i'm like man
you know what you know what the problem
is though
it's definitely not me
i think it's
everybody else yeah i can't possibly
have
it's unreal it's the best clip on the
internet
that's why he's so angry
[Music]
so sad virgin temple virgin tune pool is
getting angry at the chad's sam cedar
i'm a chad compared to tim poole
[Laughter]
that's crazy
i'm your chad husband
anyway that's it that's all i've got
about that
i'm getting out pretty good eh
you guys did a good job what sketch
right
why are you still here
right
how's your leg feeling though oh my leg
oh my god i feel like that's here
i fell off the chair
and the chair has like a
l-shaped metal bar oh and i fell with
all my weight on
no yeah there's a real
i have actually i don't know if you can
see but from the side there's like uh
careful with what you're uh you're
showing a lot of skin here yeah we're
gonna get an ass shot
come
[Laughter]
there's a bump here yeah no it's i got i
have
that's probably the most pain i've
experienced in a long long time i
thought i actually thought it impaled me
i thought i was gonna have to go to the
hospital
i was genuinely writhing and pain the
face you made i i thought you may have
got penetrated i can't think of a better
word
penetrated
there's a point going up yeah i'm glad
you didn't i wasn't sure like if we
should kept rolling with it or what oh
yeah i thought you i mean you're a great
actor to begin with so i didn't want to
reshoot it
yeah so bill cosby went free
i mean
by some weird technicality yeah i read
about it this morning how like basically
they promised him
whatever
so then they had to keep their promise
some dumb ass uh district attorney
promised they wouldn't charge him a
lawsuit
he made a plea deal
and part of that was that he would give
a statement and then
that was supposed to be protected but
then they used that statement in
his uh
[ __ ]
what's happening here
you have a flamingo hat is the chicken
well i i i was wearing like some pretty
flamboyant stuff last week so i thought
i'd just bring it down a little bit
today you're dressing down
wear some more something more casual
something i wear every day
is this like traditional swedish garb oh
yeah yeah this is just
normal stuff let me just oh
it's good i love that that's sick
that's sick you get it do you get a lot
of flamingos in sweden is it
like it's probably cold it's a little
cold for them so anyway you just fall
over sorry then to cut you off like that
anyway this district attorney
from some technical what a dumb ass so
they used the statement that they gave i
mean this is just dumb why would they
use a statement that he gave with the
condition they couldn't charge him to
charge him yeah why would they even do
that
because these da's are really just dumb
stupid
you know
that is pretty dirty though so i get why
it was thrown out but like
now people are taking it as oh he's
innocent it's like the oj thing great
yeah it's actually even oj thing was
well he was acquitted bill cosby was
let out on a technicality
but here we so uh
the supreme court justice made a
statement and summed it all up as to his
release they said we hold that when a
prosecutor makes an unconditional
promise yeah exactly what i said
here's cosby walking free justice
prevails
we will overcome
[Music]
where the ladies at
you got what's the what's that date uh
that the drug he used there's like a
chemical
it's like
tmg or no it's like ghb yeah ghb hey
let's go get that ghb oh
let's hit the boss
let's go get some [ __ ]
[Music]
i may not see but i can smell that [ __ ]
[Music]
let's go get that
[Music]
ngb
whatever it is
[Music]
let's hope this people
he's innocent that's what they're doing
now yeah but you're not it's a
technicality exactly that's the thing
bag of turret you know flamingos
[Music]
any you ladies thirsty
somebody said this happened because we
lost the cosby doll i was just gonna say
oh i thought it was first i didn't want
that [ __ ]
who got rid of the cosby doll you did
this who did it maybe i planned zack's
car i don't know no but where is it and
zach's what's actually he put it on the
back here and it disappeared
it's gone zach ran into white claw gabe
the next day i don't know that's what
was it the next day what are you talking
about is that you think he gave it to
white clock game i don't know i just
wouldn't put the blame on me for
everything i wasn't even blaming you
with the hell you're done well
any ladies out there want to get a drink
now that i'm free
i'm a good cook i make a mean jello
come back to my house and let's have
some drinks
it's so messed up
oh my god
dude this world is so [ __ ] there's no
justice
i mean yeah oj is just golfing oh oj
comments on this you're gonna love this
yeah ojs oj is uh yeah now he's an
influencer yeah he's not
i'm taking my lawyer out for a drink
after this
i mean and you think that um james
charles should be in jail i mean let's
let's start here oh yeah
oh yeah
you can take this inside if you want
right here
204 that's the number of women i have
day raped
and i'm free scot-free who's thirsty
hey everybody
we
want to thank
love it
[ __ ]
love it
this world is [ __ ]
absolutely what did oj yeah so oj
of course you know
blocked me on twitter by the way oj's
blocked me on twitter respect
it's pretty awesome hey twitter world
this is yours truly
uh oj you know
i think it's pretty respectful to get
blocked by oj that's kind of [ __ ]
epic yeah it didn't take long either i
was pretty aggressive that means you're
a good citizen
right
right it's a citizen twitter arrest
so by the way this this thing from oj
wasn't
this isn't from like yesterday this was
from a little bit ago yeah this is oj
basically saying he should have just
admitted to it so he'd get out of it
he's like that's what i did i just said
i did it so i could get out of it here's
oj's sage advice from a lifetime
criminal
murder oh jesus hey twitter world it's
me yours truly welcome
it's me jojo here with some murder tips
here uh another man got away with a
heinous crime out here on the golf
course
let's have drinks bill i'll bring my
girlfriends
these things this week uh one thing
early in the week when i was still
watching cable news i should say cable
opinion shows they had an interview with
caitlyn jenner and and they asked
her a question about her qualifications
to be governor and she gave a curious
answer she said back in 76 i faced down
the russians
well i can only think she was talking
about the olympics when she won the
decathlon the gold medal uh i was there
i was working the game for abc i was on
the goal line when he actually uh won
that 15 uh 100 meter metric miler to
cinch the decathlon um but
a gold medal is qualifications to be
governor that means sugar ray leonard he
won a gold medal then he wouldn't fire
him
even the late leon stinks won a gold
medal and i don't think he would have
qualified
by
winning a gold medal to run for governor
in any event
you know i murdered two innocent people
bill cosby decided as far as murderers
go i probably have the best golf shot
not to take a course
uh sexual course in prison and it
probably cost him his parole
so he's not getting out well when i was
in camp i took anything all the courses
i wanted to get home to my kids i took a
victim impact course that was
particularly galling to me because i had
to get up and apologize to my victims
and i got up and said guys i'm sorry i
caught you trying to sell my stolen
property i'm sorry i yelled at you and
i'm sorry that the state of california
ruled it was my property gave it back to
me and you didn't get to make any money
off my stolen property
anyway i also killed two people
but i would have taken a a cooking a
sewing class i would have taken anything
to to get home and get out of prison and
i'm sure something like our buddy is not
saying she already took those courses at
usc
in any event julio jones this is the
most carefree murder on earth you
probably can help them more than any
other team but the 49ers your coach kyle
shanahan who was there no he's the
incoherent the [ __ ] is this video
anyway you know now that bill cosby's
out we figured um
he's looking to make some money he spent
a lot of money on lawyers right and i'm
not a lot of people are willing to work
with him now let's be honest so
um
we actually got a hold of this pitch
deck
of james charles doing uh some
collaborations some makeup palettes with
bill cosby they have a lot in common you
know
they have a lot in common
and i feel like they'd be a good match
so i'm pitching this to them
announcing james charles bill cosby free
bird palette collab
they're free as a bird
you know
beautiful
beautiful and that dislike ratio though
that's right yeah but you know what
they're getting paid and they're out
there and they're just they're being
them
they're free and that's all that matters
james charles x bill cosby free bird
palette
a popsicle stick a pudding
it comes with a brush that's cool
i wonder if there's any kind of uh
substance in there that might make me
pass out
that would really tie together
oh we've got the names of the um of the
colors we're gonna pitch to them
more popsicle oh there's some kind of
pill in this popsicle stick
a little sketchy
i didn't even catch that's a little
sketchy this one's called cell wall
white right
which we don't want to be in cells we're
free birds
jumpsuit orange of course of course who
can forget that it's a beautiful color
once you get used to it
yeah
injustice indigo
nice
speckles statutory silver of course
you know
roofie red not that is a bit that maybe
that's too much that's that's just not
sensitive
the green mile
of course none of neither of them were
on death row but
we like to just think like oh it could
be worse
could always be worse
i could be on death row for selling weed
it's funny that people actually get like
horribly punished
putting pop brown
that's my favorite color
oh this i'm sure james charles named
this one little boy blue that's
that was james bell's idea for sure
brunette armpit hair that was jake
charles
repeat offender orange oh i didn't know
that you get speckles when you come back
for the second time
that's special
so yeah this will definitely sell out so
yeah i have a feeling there there's
there's gonna be a lot of high demand
for this death to all of them
way too far
so you know what what enjoy uh you know
shout out to bill cosby who's free
and james charles who's been fully
vindicated now he's put out his video so
now's the perfect time to get your free
bird
makeup palette
maybe we could have a drink later james
um
and at the same time we got a britney
update
this week so yeah there's a brick again
it's like bro there's nothing it's like
the whole world's like just free this
britney a lot of injustice no yeah just
no
but bill cosby we can do something about
bill clinton
yeah there was a free britney update
judge there was a judge denied the
request to remove britney's father as
co-conservator okay bye i'm done
what the [ __ ] there's no justice in this
world there's no justice and this world
i haven't read the details but do they
say why
what's the reason for this everything's
kind of hush huss on the back they say
um
well they said they said that the
request to remove him as conservator is
denied without prejudice
right which means they can relitigate it
and an important thing to note is that
this motion was happening for a while
and does not take into account the
testimony that we listened to last week
so they'll have a future okay yeah this
is not over and yeah them dismissing it
without prejudice means they can try
again okay
in february the judge denied the request
to remove jamie for the time being but
jamie's removal is not completely off
the table the judge pushes shouldn't be
made at a later date
um
the next hearing is scheduled for july
14th
right around the corner
here i'll give you the timeline since
her testimony june 23rd britney gives
her testimony
uh asking her dad to leave the
conservatorship
uh june 29th jamie
files a motion for investigation on
brittany's claims made
so he's fighting this her dad is
fighting this yeah yeah he he claims he
loves his daughter this is all for her
own good and um you know she's not
hasn't he made enough money just to
just go have a vacation somewhere i also
saw that
um someone said that
the post on her instagram page are like
recycled like she's not even posting
them probably oh she's there's repost
was she the one that was told
about the paparazzi that we've covered
on wednesday really yeah i don't know
yeah we watched it together about like
don't take pictures of me at the beach
if i don't look good or whatever oh
right no i i was saying really to the
recycling yes um
well yeah according to she's still in
the conservatorship she doesn't have
control of her life right right
on june 30th the court gave an official
document to make blah blah blah
yeah not that interesting
free britney
free brittany
lock up bill cosby
this is bizarre i am seeing repost from
videos just reposting [ __ ] it's like
she's still trying to warn us you guys
are still surprised this isn't her
account no like no she's fully in the
conservatorships though
it's britney [ __ ] nothing has changed
dude her dad is like an actual villain
man that is
crazy i hope she does like a book or a
tell-all
i would watch the [ __ ] out of like a
free britney documentary with her in it
man that would be good
i'm going to support her let's get
britney like a
a a a gofundme
[ __ ] building the wall let's free
brittany i don't know what that would do
necessarily i'll set it up i'll take the
money
you know like every other youtuber i'm
going to set up for free brittany i'll
be like is going to help
what do you think what do you think
about a free britney coin
a commemorative coin no well that's good
too i was thinking more like a crypto
coin of something free britney
brittany crypto coin going to the moon
baby we're going to make a free britney
crypto coin i'll do a huge promotion
sell it immediately right i'll own like
90 of it sell it immediately yeah and
make like uh 10 million dollars
free britney nfc
and oh she'll make sure her family gets
a cut of the action what about uh we
call it brit connect
brick
[Applause]
bro well done
that's [ __ ] good
oh yeah i just care about brittany
a commemorative coin is fun too like you
see on the shopping channels at 3am
free britney commemorative coin get it
now for a thousand dollars well just i
feel obligated to read this slide
somebody just donated a hundred dollars
three times in a row this is for one of
uh this is for all the white
nationalists stephen crowder fans in the
chat thank you for being foot soldiers
uh what does that mean
he's sarcastically saying people that
because you have to be a member to chat
so he's goofy is there okay yeah he said
use and then he said use it for your
team of lawyers and love bot t he
uh with peace and love tim poole is the
only person i wouldn't want to see
wearing a teddy fresh bean oh that was
his that's that was that same person
this guy's full of of peace and love now
thanks john
dropping big cats thank you thank you
flaming turd badge straight into setting
up the brick connect coin thank you so
much connect
brick connect that's so good
good one zach
thank you i think thanks dan um it was
okay is there people who are like
simping for tim paul in the chat i
wouldn't expect that i didn't catch any
of that but i mean there's always i'm
sure there's someone out there i i it
always do you think i'm ruining
everything
there's people
is is damaging everything making it all
worse
what the [ __ ] did i do
i'm gonna get pissed off about that
yeah
yeah everybody in the world is the
reason why tim pulls single
this guy is a manipulative lying con man
this was another great story that i have
uh have you seen what happened in the
tour de force toward the force toward
the front
this was a this was a security force of
a fuck-up for sure there's a bunch of
jedis
and i get once again i'm just i'm sick
of people i'm sick
of people
i'm [ __ ] sick of it
how dumb can you be man i think he went
off the road the road has got a nasty
ridge on it there no
the rider in front hits a total disaster
and that is the result
and taking this within like a minute of
it
this was like the race started in
immediately
this person ruined the entire [ __ ]
and then he probably got in the meat
grinder because he got run over by a lot
of people there were there were three uh
three injuries that um
required people to go to the hospital oh
my god which i think is actually pretty
good considering
yeah what a huge pile up
the worst part is these poor guys
they spend their whole life
preparing for this
tour de france and they're like just
the race is just ruined
i'm gonna i'm gonna mute it
so it said something like shout out to
grandma and grandpa and then
the best thing is that this woman
was it a moment i think it was a woman
right i think so is a woman who did it
yes she bailed afterwards she was like
at large she went on the lane yeah she
was on the run
living out in timothy mcveigh style out
in the woods did they end up getting her
what she turned herself in after several
days of like a international manhunt wow
yeah they were gonna apparently the the
tour was planning on suing her and stuff
but then they're like they dropped the
charge but one of the racers who got
injured is actually going to file a suit
against her and she is getting some
criminal charges
it wasn't she claims it was an accident
well sure it was for sure an accident
she's just an idiot like
landing in
yeah watch the first guy well he can't
move and he can't break exactly that's
such a larry david
and can you match this is totally what
happened to larry david do you see this
uh thing that i'm highlighting here
you got to show this too oh there's more
uh yeah and it's just it's a catastrophe
what a [ __ ]
you can you can't write this stuff man
oh she's
people are saying that
they're comparing the manhunt for her
as a game of where's waldo she has the
blue pants in the red and white striped
shirt just like waldo oh my god
the whole country or the whole continent
of europe was looking for
can people just stop
yeah she spent four days on the run and
finally turned herself in wow
you know i was having a conversation
with dan about like people post covid
it's like they're not there's you know
an element of interaction that's just
off now they're not ready to uh to
reintegrate you're right yeah yeah
maybe
i don't think they were ever ready some
of these people
um um
we don't have ads so there's no like ad
break so i'm going to go pee you know
you want to take you want to take the
reins here for a minute
all right i've got quite a few donations
stacked up actually i don't want the
donations
[Laughter]
[Music]
alyssa donated a hundred dollars and
said prison said i let's let bill out
we'll take james now yeah
not a great uh
not a great that would be nice if they
said that but
i don't think anything is happening to
james unfortunately
it's very strange like we've talked
about i mean
i
i don't know ethan had that theory that
um
when the uh
victims in these sort of online scandals
are a young underage girl people take it
way more seriously and at the time i
kind of balked at that i was like i
don't know if i believed that but this
whole situation really has made me kind
of
it's strange i mean
all these guys
you know were victimized in
the same way that uh you know
you hear stories who was the the other
youtuber that is in jail right now for
basically doing what james did once
right um i don't know the name i know
you're talking about i forget his name
yeah um
yeah i wasn't i know of the story but i
wasn't following it but yep yeah so i
don't know i don't know but um
sometimes these things take a long time
so
no it still might be coming down the
pipe
and like he said he's not planning to
stop so
yeah
that sounds right i think i'm sure the
chat's going to start spamming the
second one austin jones i think so
i think that name sounds familiar um
what else we got uh
15
donation you guys are [ __ ] rock
stars please don't stop exposing the
sociopaths of the internet who hide it
in plain sight much love
you got it we will not stop doing that
uh
somebody donated 10 bucks whoever
donated and said they want ela vlogs i
second that i would love a day in the
life with our ceo and super mom
i don't think she has time to do that
i'm feeling definitely
all day every day i gotta tell you guys
she really
it's crazy lately like teddy fresh is
just growing so much and we're putting
in
a lot of effort to like really build a
a strong foundation
to the company so that it's a legit
business with different departments and
structure and it's like
lately it's actually exhausting
it's super exciting though i'm every day
i'm like i love
my job i mean it's amazing i just i
can't really believe that it's become
what it is stone but totally
i got one fish
[Laughter]
but
i have like barely time to breathe or
stop and eat lunch it's crazy
i i get that i i know that it sounds
really cool to have vlogs but i don't
know that it would be
because it's a lot of technical stuff a
lot of meetings a lot of what i do i
probably can't share until later that's
true too right yeah like we
we work on stuff almost like a year
ahead
um
and it takes a while until it looks like
it looks at the end like right it's a
long process
but um
i love it you're taking too long on the
fish mine
[Laughter]
[Music]
um what else we got uh
20 donation i wore my teddy fresh nighty
last night it was super soft and comfy i
love it long time fan of the fupa and
the troopa
potato
oh that's a name sorry
um
somebody donated 20 and said re i assume
that was when we were talking about uh
tim poole any comments about uh trisha's
weight dan oh god
dan
dan was set up okay it was
you can say what happened baby
love set him up
love to be dirty i didn't want to throw
him under the bus
nutritious
you want to send it down
[ __ ] you damn no well i can explain what
happened
should i yeah go ahead
yeah so
we have a chat where i send the
donations and
i sent
a image of the donation
and i was a bit slow on the text and i
basically said don't read these comments
or destination yeah you said that a
little bit afterwards
yeah it was like right after it was like
don't read this and i was just like well
it's hard i already said it what a
moment man what a moment oh it's so good
so it was nice i can take the blame on
that not done
um yeah dan's had a rough week he almost
almost died yesterday
i've never seen i don't know what
happened to daniel
i was almost in a uh pretty serious car
accident on the freeway really somebody
almost uh ran me off the [ __ ] road
yeah oh my god pretty intense was there
any collision
uh no i like i [ __ ] fast and the
furious dude like
it was crazy i don't know it was like
one of those adrenaline
my instincts took over tell me what
happened
i mean it's i was i was driving along
and i just heard squealing i looked to
my left and there was a car oh my god
pretty much 90 degrees per you know
on the freeway on the freeway skid out
uh yeah so i thought it was a blowout
that was like my
in the in that moment i was like they
had a tire blow out and they're like
swerving to the side
and there was a car
in my way on the other side of me um
kind of like in my blind spot so i had
to like
swerve hard and speed up and get out of
there and i almost like fishtailed uh
getting out of there but i managed
somehow i managed to keep control of the
car was there a crack um there was no
crash but then i i like slowed down i
was like holy [ __ ] and i was expecting
the car that did that to also slow down
because i assumed their tire blew out
and instead they speed up and i see
they are like road raging with another
car and they're like they're chariot
racing they're like trying like they're
kicking it like down the freeway at like
70 miles an hour [ __ ] [ __ ]
humanity is done yeah
humanity is over yeah this [ __ ]
experiment is a failure dan doesn't want
to admit the true reason why did that
happen yesterday
go ahead
well we he brought up uh
exactly why are you going zach you're
doing it to yourself but you're doing it
to yourself clarence
because we had a conversation
exactly that's why it happened every
single after we talked about it on the
show every single person in his office
experienced some type of bad luck you're
an idiot
every time clearance clearwater plays a
song on the radio it's true you guys
don't want to [ __ ] believe me
the crazy thing is people think you're
kidding but you're not i'm
my hand of [ __ ] god you brought it up
this time like
no sympathy if you
because
for the people that don't know
is that zach has a i guess i will call
it a phobia of the band clarence
clearwater
whatever the
and every time zach hears it on the
radio something terrible happens he's so
to the point where he can't even hear he
has trouble even listening
i can't say the [ __ ] name he can't
say the name
or or the person that is the instructor
of that band so i refer to it as the
band the band but there is the band so
how do you refer to the band
he just doesn't know he brings it up on
this i'm a big band
levon helms band
robbie robertson's your summer just got
[ __ ] over bro i hope you're okay so so
wait so i swear
so were you listening to uh claire
clarence
no so why are we talking because
dan brought the name up yesterday he
brought the name he brought it up man he
[ __ ] brought it up and and this [ __ ]
happens now thank god you're okay dan it
happened in it happened yesterday
morning
no no no the day before we were talking
about that how long does the curse last
if someone mentions it you have 24 to 48
hours that's the curse window dude
nothing happens to me but it could have
happened
i'm just i'm just saying in this case it
was good luck i i didn't i disagree
somebody ccr or john was in heaven
looking down upon me and i know he's not
dead but he's still
in the future he's looking down the
[ __ ] fact you're in that predicament
though don't you think there's some
i dare i say credence to it
you may not say that
okay let me ask you this the members of
that band did they have like gruesome
tragedy no and everyone loves their
[ __ ] music and i'm not denying their
music is bad i'm not denying that okay
i'm just saying on a personal level this
[ __ ] is cursed exactly
is there a possibility that you're wrong
no
and you know people have their own
beliefs this is my belief all
possibilities this is where dan is this
is religious persecution right now from
dan
what what
what is your religion
it's not believing in this [ __ ]
cursed band
zack
zack is so interesting
jesus let's let's test it out let's spam
jamie spears comments
wait what if someone said someone said
good thing that ethan can't actually say
it
the band's called clarence's clearwaters
you can't play the music so i'm set i'm
safe there it's called creedence
clearwater revival why are you revival
apparently we can't even say their name
right you can't just yeah let's let's
bleep those
wait i can't watch the live show
and post you know
wait so zack you said
last time we brought it up bad stuff
happened to all of us right
yeah
oh you son of a [ __ ]
so you bring it i played one second of
one of their songs and he knew it
immediately
all i heard was
and he muted but
i feel like you're on a good point like
go ahead
you said that stuff happened all of us
last time you mentioned it and then you
brought it up today which you're kind of
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] really yeah you
brought it up
that's like making all of us watch the
ring
vhs tape right i just wanted to point it
out all right that's all i'm saying man
but based on your logic you shouldn't
even point it out
yes
based on your logic i should have died
in a fiery wreck instead of miraculously
escaping based on my logic you shouldn't
have been in that predicament
why why there's something from the
[ __ ]
don't worry i know how to time it
[Music]
that's it
zach has left the building
he's gone
but you so that he's actually serious
that's the thing that is kind of wild
here though
god
well now you have 48 hours to we're
going to disprove the curse this time
zach
okay man we have 48 hours we're going to
protect you okay man you know it's we
have someone who feels the same as zach
but over a different band oh really
which one the cars it's not the car but
zach if somebody else has this curse
about another band don't you see that
maybe your theory is a little thin no
i'm right
based on i mean based on personal
experience man like
i don't want to leave him hanging
because we have talked about this i
don't believe in it but there is a weird
coincidence that after after that
episode i had really bad luck
all right
i agree with you my life's going great
actually well okay then good for [ __ ]
you dan
well then you did almost die in the park
thank you
thanks to you having vin diesel like
fast and furious nine you you were on
the freeway in that second in that
[ __ ] moment right in that what you
know what what are you [ __ ]
happening we've been having this
conversation for months now like when
did you first tell me this like six
months ago there's someone that feels
this way about nickelback
just saying not everybody can have a
cursed band it doesn't make sense
not everyone can have a curse band but
i'm right
clear clearance
[Laughter]
clear clearance is the real curse
okay what's the radius what's the radius
where it affects because clearly it's
not going to affect people like in india
right we need to burn some sage in this
building we need to say a prayer i mean
you know what i don't know
one might say
that there's no such thing as a
coincidence
did you see this healer
no what a segway there is no that was
impressive once again
the fact that you're watching this video
means you're just aligned with me and
this message
your thoughts create your reality we're
homies of course i saw this
and now we're homies with this guy
because he um duetted me
and then i redo edit him today and now
i'm going to try to get him on the show
because there's no such thing as
acquaintance let's be honest there's not
we are i let's be honest at this point i
am energetically aligned with him right
can we actually talk to him and ask him
about this
this one like what happened there that's
my that's right yeah
there is no such thing as a coincidence
the fact that clarence clean water
reborns play
thank god you can't say
it's proof that there's no such thing as
a coins everybody watching this stream
is energetically aligned with me right
now and we'll all fall victim to james
charles on snapchat and nothing will
happen there's no president
there's no such thing as a coincidence
there's no such thing as a coincidence
crypto is out now
everybody buy it
and there's no such thing as a
coincidence that i will sell it and pull
the rug out of all your feats
well anyway
um
he did a follow-up to his uh freaking up
the lady so here you go you you tell me
what you take of this if you think this
is
him admitting if it was real or what i
don't know
i have trouble deciphering his
his with all this talk about the
screaming woman
yo we can't play the [ __ ] sound oh
what happened to the woman and why did i
choose to upload it i'm pretty sure his
music is uh all royalty-free [ __ ] that
he uses in there i think so that one
uh i guess i i don't know 100 so i guess
i'll read it i'm good at it it's more
fun for me with all this talk about the
screaming woman
and my lack of reaction you're probably
wondering what happened to the woman and
why did i choose to upload it what
happened she just would you just kept
walking you're not reading a wise person
once said the majority of problem with
life is learning how to deal with costly
interruptions
who said that
today's message
next time you get a negative thought
interrupt it with gratitude
[Music]
so that's what that look was so i'm
assuming he's trying to say it was real
yeah he's clearly it has to be real
or otherwise he should work at snl
who's the wise person who said that
doesn't matter
i'm curious because now i want to know
if it was him or it's probably him
he's like a wise person who just made
this up who happens
so here he here's me talking about it
such a deep rabbit hole and there's [ __ ]
no such thing as a coincidence guy
in a video from 2016. now that this gets
even creative
coincidence which trisha payton and then
guess who's this girl right that's
another one that's the girl we were
talking about like an episode or two ago
she was the 16 year old courtney stodden
yeah who was married to like a 50 year
old or whatever she was married to the
fifth year from the green mile the
shitty guard
the way he walks away everything comes
connected
dude there is truly no such thing as a
coincidence
there's no such thing as a coincidence
he posted uh can you link the video i
made a b down here yeah he posted an
instagram q a picture about the
screaming woman
why did she scream
human instincts oh god
what instinct did she
feel off you that made her want to
scream and why are you using this
[Laughter]
there is no such thing as a coincidence
so anyway i retweeted his
or reduetted whatever the [ __ ] you
caught on
so this is such a deep rabbit hole
trisha paytas with the no such thing as
a coincidence guy
in a video from 2016. now this gets even
crazier no such thing as a coincidence
but you should pick you get it so you're
directing to the duet yes exactly maybe
he'll do it to my duet and you get the
story let's see
yeah i'm saying that was the emma do you
follow each other well so i've been
following him for a while but he doesn't
follow me like bro why you gotta be such
a diva
you're gonna do at me and act like you
know we're energetic how are you gonna
act like we're energetically aligned and
you're not gonna follow me on tick tock
if you're watching this no such thing as
coincidence guy i want you on the show
yes so follow me on tick tock
and the fact that you're watching this
is proof that we're energetically alive
there's no such thing as a coincidence
[Music]
hey bill cosby here
uh what there's no such thing as a
coincidence would you like to get a
drink with me
are we entering your nightmares
there's no such thing as a coincidence
[Laughter]
the fact that my ghb is in your drink
right now means that we are
energetically aligned
there is no such thing as a coincidence
is that a pill in the jello pop there's
no such thing as a coincidence
stop
all right you're the one playing that
zach
that wasn't me
oh
okay oh wow we got more wow there's
multi
multi sound effects going on here dan's
got like the best of he's got the hits
he's got the hits
i'm low key people don't know this but
i'm i got it i got a sound board too
well
yeah dan dan come
um zach people are saying we have the
same hair now
that's funny
what's your plan
i'm letting it grow out i'm getting rid
of the blonde [ __ ] you're getting rid of
it yeah i'll probably cut you know
in a little you know maybe a month or
two
i was told by the doctor to wait a
little longer before i do any color
so i'm that's why they can cause again
that's interesting right it can cause
birth defects i mean he's coloring he
said that they're not sure but he was
like if i were you i wouldn't so i was
like okay
no more yeah
i uh it just totally [ __ ] my hair up
yeah the bleach i bleached it three
times yeah just my hair is like still
hay you know yeah mine too a little bit
would you say there's no such thing as a
coincidence
listen i don't want to get into this but
i'm going to [ __ ] it
what
jeff
oh [ __ ] daddy dolbreck listen to this
guy
this guy's got no [ __ ] cell phones
loved it like it was some big major clap
back like you guys how to [ __ ] fight
live that fell apart while eating he's
talking about frenemies when it was
pizza it was live it was live
[ __ ]
i mean you guys don't edit kingdom but
it's not live
he corrects himself oh i've never seen
that or no actually it wasn't even live
they chose to air their fights and
that's content that's the content you
want to make look people love the jeff
jeff
did he make a ten part documentary about
his friend
smashing his skull
you want to talk about that's content
your friend best friend who you're still
doing videos
attempted to murder you with an
excavator
okay ethan
what the [ __ ] bro
the fact that you are energetically
aligned with david dobrik right now
you can't be saying anything about oh
that's content seriously
drama you know they love the [ __ ]
they used to eat pizza and argue and
argue about money and your relationship
fell apart and then you sabotage each
other's families and the biggest deepest
darkest secrets yeah that's toxic okay
i'm still friends with the kid
what's his point
i was just like dude stop your friend
david dobrik filmed someone getting
assaulted i mean it's fine he's not
saying anything really um
that anyone is like
not saying anyone else is not saying i
mean yeah it was pretty toxic yeah i
agree
and then we all kind of agree on very
insightful yeah but it's just it's just
ironic a little bit
oh trisha tricia i call her trisha
paytas now like i don't know her
trisha she woke up to jeff whitake
threatening me this morning what'd you
guys think of this because i i thought
he was going a little wild to be honest
with you and can you guys pull the tweet
he sent to kat like this morning or
yesterday too it should be in there
i always oh yeah i see it thank you i
always feel like
it's the lowest thing you could do um
share private conversations oh sure
that's dude that being said what he's
saying in here is also pretty it's off
the rails
yeah it's
both parties are i don't know what
happens when you're both off the rails i
don't know
you get back on the rails no no it's
like two negatives yeah i woke up to
jeff whitake threatening me this morning
um i literally commented on a segment
you were talking about me and stuff so
he texts her
and he goes i'm not going to have an
internet beef with you
i don't even know why he's texting her
you crossed the line
i'm just giving wait
is there more
no but he's basically saying like
i'm just giving you a heads up like
keep doing your thing but i don't know
what he said no wait this isn't the
whole conversation he sent her one that
says not gonna end good for any of us
or it's not going to end good for you if
you keep talking about me where's that
maybe
he takes that five percent
what the [ __ ] did i just click to
here let's go with this
oh it's the crop i think it's the crop
the twitter does so when you need when
you click on the picture it shows more
oh
let's see
nothing's loading so we love that
and it doesn't show oh well this is a
screenshot so link me yeah so i'll find
the original link
oh my god well if what am i supposed to
do no i'm not laughing at you i'm
laughing at whoever screenshotted a
tweet without
expanding the actual relevant part
fess up drama time to get dragged no i'm
kidding oh let's not drink
we love you guys we work on tough
schedules
we work you know
five percent
[Laughter]
well while we pull up that tweet
you can see how he responded to her
he goes nobody cares you little rat
he goes why do everyone associate with
being a criminal he goes
i'm much more than a dude who just went
to jail for selling drugs meanwhile
nobody cares you rat
like he's a mobster or something go to
the police maybe they'll sit through
your 10 hours of videos
i think cat got involved by the way
cat's the girl he sent his fans after
now are we talking here freely
yeah of course everyone always
cat
has really got to chill like
oh oh
i
just i keep seeing her and getting
involved in twitter drama and it's not a
good look for a reporter it's just not
she i totally agree like she just
shouldn't she got to choose the lane are
you serious journalist or are you
twitter it just doesn't make her look
like serious and legitimate right
unfortunately i you know we were rooting
for her when she wrote the article about
david dobrik so i'm not like
not
trying to talk badly about her but
i it's been difficult to watch her on
twitter that's a good insight i agree
with you
good point hilo
she says yeah the guy in the vlog squad
are so nice it's so surprising they got
into a big scandal
she says this is a guy who illegally
recorded me without my consent to try to
prove that i had ill intentions then
made millions off his toxic workplace
just to continue work there he said
nobody cares you fake reporter
nobody cares nobody cares i guess that's
the truth nobody gives a [ __ ] david's
back james is back nobody cares
bye-bye he's right
i wish he wasn't but he is right
nobody cares you fake reporter
didn't you apolo wait did it you got to
make up your mind though jeff didn't you
apologize to her
for saying she was like a fake reporter
and now he's yeah because he admitted
that he didn't read the article yeah uh
bro did you even read the article now
and you're still on your fake reporter i
never understood why you guys let him
off the hook so bad when like that
interview that we did with him he's the
dumbest [ __ ] i've ever met in my
life well he's also kind of a dick like
i was like oh he's a nice guy he's
willing to come i appreciate he was
willing to come but he's actually kind
of a dick too yeah no [ __ ] let me just
clarify in case he's watching i'm maybe
that's dangerous
it's not me
i'm the one i got canceled for defending
you and your buddy so right like this
guy
well and the first time he thought i was
you right and was like bringing up tick
tock or something he's like oh i saw him
on here [ __ ] you're talking about i
literally knew nothing about him at the
time everything i've learned about him
has been since that interview and that
was not a great introduction because
that interview man
i don't know what the [ __ ] he was
thinking so jeff just tell me ha when
you called her a fake reporter now on
june 30th at 6 41 p.m have you read the
article
okay
[Laughter]
he's actually like a total dick
yeah
um here let's find the interaction with
with trisha which
thank you
i actually uh
i thought oh here this this is where
just so the shortest side for you guys
this is a image that eli just took of
the dogs
it's kind of new that alfredo will
uh sleep in a donkey bed love them
because he was like a straight dog
yeah he likes to sleep on hard circles
he just lives on the floor
right
and um
he's learning from shredder how to
live the high life
shredder's bougie as [ __ ]
wait this is cardi b's real twitter
account yeah i just went and verified uh
wait what yeah
cardi b's pictures and no such thing as
a coincidence
no way
yeah
what
why is this guy infiltrating everything
how did that happen okay here she
probably saw him thought it was [ __ ]
hilarious i mean oh my god is pretty
wild but there's cardi b's twitter
account
wow
i know such things
profile picture i should change mine too
[ __ ] it oh my god i want to change
everyone
there's no such thing as a coincidence
why it is happening did you just do it
and not say anything you don't scroll oh
it gets it gets not safe for work okay i
kinda lose just kinda
oh my god you guys
[Music]
how is this real
oh
that's crazy
there is no such thing as a quincy we
need that the what's it what is that
okay where's the where's the twit the
tricia thing i'm not seeing it you guys
it's on discard where
huh oh what are you looking for right
here if you said it's on discord i've
been waiting this whole time for the
trisha first sorry adhd
i sent it in minions chat i'm not a
minion
you're not opinion that's for sure my
bad
it's there now
this show is a well-oiled machine
all right
all right you know what i'm just gonna
i'm gonna
i'm sorry dan
i'm gonna expose you why what did i do
this tweet is from an account you muted
stop
[Laughter]
what are you referring to oh it's the
podcast well somebody muted her on the
podcast
i don't think it was me but can you
blame them no no i'm just saying i just
thought it was funny
you're putting that on me oh james
charles is trending right now oh i gotta
read through this
the
adhd can you finish with this tweet i
was trying
to be sent never sent me the link yes it
did but it's okay
all right here it is
poke away at my injury it's gonna end
really bad for everyone
we can't make fun it's like what
she said huh
i'm not gonna have an internet beef with
you
okay you said something about me i'm not
allowed to respond you're crossing the
line what did she say
does anyone aware
honestly
about any of this jesus and don't care
seriously no i think just a bunch of
goofballs
well i'm talking about jeff and i'm
trying to get to the bottom of it just
using his injury against him that's the
gist of it okay do your thing just a kid
well is this a thr anyway i was just
curious what you guys think this
statement poke away at my injury it's
going to end really bad for everyone
what does that mean
it does sound like a threat he sounds
like i'm going to kill myself and you
i'm taking everybody out
that's what it sounds like i don't know
okay yeah so sorry guys after dark h3
adh3
so sorry for actually trying to just
care talk about something i care about
it's actually adhd how about james
charles twitter or h3id i do want to
hear what people are saying about this
five percent
yeah not james charles talking about his
inappropriate behavior with minors while
doing a makeup tutorial for sure
how do you hold yourself accountable
than to delete the video of you holding
yourself accountable good question
every time he says he like grew so much
and he educated himself and then he goes
and says something really dumb but he
gets away with it every time crazy the
like ratio on that video was
mad
james charles i'm not trying to make
light of this situation also james
charles i'm gonna do my makeup while i
talk about underage victims who accuse
me of essay
yep
this picture is awesome
james charles really got his ass back on
youtube i agree man i cannot believe it
word the fox we're [ __ ] we're all
[ __ ] bye
hey jeff you can come do a double
homicide on me and you i don't care
anymore
he's like it's gonna end bad for both of
us what else would that mean
he's gonna go do a suicide bomb
it could mean he's going to dig up old
texts uh
gabby style to expose her
i don't know i don't know that guy's a
criminal he's i think he means death to
all of them
stop
that guy's a criminal death to all of
them
did you miss that okay whatever moving
on
he's a criminal we're just talking about
it he went to jail for selling drugs
oh
not a violence
was
was is people don't change either
come on
i'm just kidding
selling drugs is like the least stupid
drugs yeah exactly not like him
well you didn't get caught stop move on
anyway um
okay so this part is really fun i i
promise what do you want to eat look at
me
mexican
we've been going so then really
that's how that's what ethan says like
every time okay you immediately two
hours so we can talk about food
that's your logic
by the way
this is me friday
this is being friday at 2 30. oh my god
this
you know what that does make me want to
mexican
red sauce and
cheese haven't been in a mexican
restaurant in like over a year
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's the chips
the salsa bar
[Music]
[Applause]
all right this one's fun this part we
leave mexican it's official i didn't say
it dan said it i'm down for anything i
just said it all right
all right triller
trailer trailer trailer
oh is that the guy that is that the
company that's run by that ceo ryan
cavanaugh right
actually just to bring you guys up to
date on who because just so you have ref
uh
point of reference
excuse me
this is ryan cavanaugh
uh he's like the basically the owner
of trailer
and uh his he's been accused of by his
partner of running a ponzi scheme
and he bankrupted relativity
which is [ __ ] awesome
because now he's trying to build triller
and he wants to go public and it's like
dude you bankrupted your last company
and you've been accused of running a
ponzi scheme it's awesome
and this is the guy who's suing us
frank cavanaugh it's his twitter account
so the funny thing is yeah which we
talked about on wednesday is that david
dobrik in the midst of being canceled
was sponsored by guess who
thriller
now here's where it's funny i'm sure
they paid him a shitload of money or
maybe they got a bargain because
because nobody
yeah it's the comeback um promotion
oh you got to link me david's triller
account you think
tick
what am i going to do with this tick
tock account i gotta need his trailer
account
you sent that that's right you should
add that to show that he's still on tick
tocks like it's nothing
it was you it was you it was you
you need me
just killer you asked to have it i want
both well okay how am i gonna compare if
i don't have a link to the trailer
here's the trailer thank you
you know what i think i want to eat
actually go ahead pasta
no
i'm on the mexican uh oh oh well we
already went over that
nobody more specific go ahead i want the
burrito
that has like the green salsa over it
[ __ ] cute
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way this is this is not mexican
music i just i feel they need to point
out
yeah please don't cancel it this is not
mexican i want that too you know
you have some mariachi
how is that not mariachi music because
it's not mariachi okay what is it that's
like salsa music or something so let me
play that as a spanish restaurant
mexican restaurant uh okay fair enough
i'm just
dude don't be stopping it's not like you
you're talking about mexican food so
you're over correcting i'm not over
correcting i was just
music
over under
here's some [ __ ] this is here we go this
is this isn't like you're it is good
[ __ ] yes it is it's not yes it is
it's not as good
turn it off zach
bring back this also
it's just not as good i mean also music
is great you never heard this song in a
mexican restaurant you serious uh no i
think that that's right
you wouldn't really
yes you would i don't i agree with ethan
you would hear this what a surprise
you know about mexican food you're from
like detroit maybe oh god yeah go to
detroit there's a lot of mexicans in
detroit
also in l.a
probably not um
no
but uh listen most most of the time dan
is right
this time well it's happy music i don't
understand the happy we were like okay
guys can we talk about triller
[Laughter]
so anyway trailer paid david a shitload
of money presumably to sponsor his dumb
[ __ ] triller account which he's
posted two videos on and bailed
his videos have like a few hundred
thousand views
and then meanwhile
this just goes to show you how shitty
and like a wasteland trailer is
meanwhile
he's posting his new videos
on tick tock
okay here just just to wrap it up the
previous discussion are we talking about
still
um
is not over correcting it's so annoying
when people say all latin music is
mexican oh my god guys that's not i
didn't say it was mexican music did i i
just i kind of implied that if you go to
a mexican restaurant you'll hear salsa
music it's not that crazy
uh i mean can i also maybe
oh by the way all mariachi music is not
all mexicans listen to by the way nobody
said that
well she this person in the chat is like
it's so annoying when people say
mariachi music is
all music is mariachi i agree with ethan
i'm sorry
zach let us know when you don't
oh yeah i can say the same for you
oh my god you're saying anything
interesting someone put them in timeout
dude
[Laughter]
come to a hundred we have a lot of uh
people in the chat or giving their
opinions okay so what
so they i mean i think that dan was not
over correcting that's all
ethan was just
excited to enjoy it
enjoy yourself it gets you in the vibe
of eating the food
it was just saying that it's not mexican
music it's just not nobody said it was
kind of music you could hear at a
mexican restaurant
maybe sometimes sure also i'm sorry the
latins don't eat or latin americans
don't eat rice and beans
what okay well it's like why are we
defining mexican food anyway
mexican food is okay pretty easy to
define i don't know it's mexican let's
talk about tick tock please
so david was paid to go put some dumbass
videos on triller
it has like a couple hundred thousand
views natalie and i just found it out of
the united states literally nothing has
changed oh by the way that clip of me
making fun of his laugh from wednesday
got removed we got suspended on tick
tock really for bull for hate speech
[Laughter]
this is hate speech
look at this
he posted the same thing on tick tock it
has 5.5 million views 1.1 million likes
and then on trailer which he posted
twice to
um
[ __ ] i closed it
but anyway he's posting all kinds of new
content and it's not even on trailer the
point is guys trailer's a wasteland
my favorite was when i when we were
working on this i opened david dobrik's
triller page
and um
and the videos weren't even showing up
their website was like bugging out
it's just like the place is just such a
mess
so i've been having fun
looking up at triller like if you go to
their app store
i gave them one star by the way on the
app just because i didn't have a
positive experience on it
yeah people should judge for themselves
though they should download the app and
then you know experience it a little bit
and maybe leave a review
sure that would be responsible yeah but
trailers product description that's so
funny triller such a scumbag company
they'll be like we got a we have 100
billion downloads meanwhile there's like
two people using it
so the their product description if you
go to the app store it says create share
connect join global stars such as josh
richards charlie demilia noah beck kevin
hart tyga and more
so they list all these celebrities so
all the people we pay for oh yeah
so i was like okay i wonder if any of
these people are still on trailer
you know that they're hyping up so i go
to noah beck he actually is still on
thriller this is his latest video from
june 29th you'll watch this it's
literally it has 30 000 views this is
the most one of the most popular
influencers in the world right now
but watch the content he's literally
just bitching about what a shitty app it
is
look at this yo trailer my thing's
flipped
my camera's like flipped around right
now but look
i'm i'm trying to uh it's so awkward
what is it doing hey guys like look it's
when i put it this way oh i see it yeah
it's weird it's like mirrored should i
head off
what a great video
that's good
so noah logged in real fast to get 30
000 views and tell triller their app is
[ __ ] up oh it's so awkward so you got
to pull this one right here yo trailer
my thing's flipped yo triller my thing
is
flipped my thing is flipped man watch
your language
noah back
kevin hart who is listed here kevin hart
uh has deleted his triller account he's
not on trailer
he does have a tick tock account though
if you fight it try to find kevin hart
on trailer he does is not there
yet in their description they say
collect with global stars such as kevin
hart
he's on tv
tyga
his last upload on triller again they
say join global stars such as tyga his
us upload was from november
of 2020
almost a year
ago uh he continues to upload on tick
tock
um
you know
actually i was browsing triller's um
review section
just to get an idea because i wanted to
know is this an app worth downloading is
this something i want to engage with
i've heard a lot about this ryan
kavanagh the owner of trailer who's like
who his partner says he's like been
involved in a ponzi scheme
so i wanted to get so i wanted to
oh so this one is by ft slider
i downloaded this app after the awesome
shout out in david dovelix doe brought
dough black's vlog
i was excited to try triller because it
seemed really cool
he said dough block dough black
david dough black duper
duper i think you may mix two creators
there david doe black dubrick
and anyway you can tell david's having a
good time on trailer with his two posts
i was super excited to try it seemed
cool but after trying the app out for a
few hours i was really not happy with
the layout and functionality of the app
it was also very glitchy that's also
similar to what dan was reporting and
noah beck incidentally
your app is flipped dude
after having a bad experience in the app
i want to do a bit of research on the
owner of this company when i did a
google it turned out that one of the
guys named ryan kavanagh
whose best friend and business partner
accused him of running a ponzi scheme
holy [ __ ] yo triller my thing's flipped
yo
this is really getting around it this
guy ryan kavanagh
was accused of running a ponzi scheme it
seems like ryan cavanaugh is a really
bad guy
that is really crazy i'm definitely
going to have to give this a one-star
rating
so awkward because of all the
circumstances
whoa that's a really useful review to me
about this driller app
that's the guy who's suing me ryan
kavanaugh he's talking about ugh it's so
awkward
should have called it [ __ ] talk someone
said
one star
this app is essentially a worse version
of tick tock with an algorithm that is
blatantly promoting certain members over
others whoa that's a crazy accusation
also not for nothing one of the guys who
made this app back this app was also
accused by one of his partners of
operating a ponzi scheme
what's his name his name is probably
ryan kevin he's probably referring to
that ryan cavanaugh you were mentioning
sounds like it yeah
trailer my thing's flipped this is him
for um
this is him for
uh for the record just so this is the
guy right
he has some he has some physical
uh relation to he resembles harvey
weinstein physically
according to you
of course it's according to according to
who else well
it wasn't good assuming it looks like
harvey weinstein no we didn't all agree
with that
um it's not it by unanimous decision
yeah
uh wait till you guys find out the
details of the lawsuit i'm almost to the
point where we're going to
i'm going to be able to do a full video
about it because i'm just waiting for us
to make a certain public filing and then
i'll read from the filing
uh the worst app ever
[Music]
it banned me for no reason
the work the app so bad that even jake
paul left it
the worst app ever it banned me for no
reason it keeps crashing when i try to
do a video and the people are weird they
want feed pictures
it's so bad do not download this oh they
even got a response
[Music]
knock off tick tock
all right thanks for your feedback
how about the knockoff tape it's a
little desperate don't you think like
they're responding to [ __ ] like that
so desperate ugh it's so awkward
this is copyright i really like the idea
but it's copying the app tick tock
thanks for your feedback
okay
this app ruined my life the day i
downloaded this app my wife told me she
wanted a divorce now i'm out of my house
and living off 20 of my own income my
wife gets the rest of it i live in a
rundown motel since my credit is ruined
and i can't
be approved for an apartment and the
worst of all my dog ran away thanks
triller
one star
that guy's definitely pinging it's
almost like he heard clarence clarence
clean water
clarence clinton
oh here's a good one cool
david dobrik brought me here so yeah
cool app five stars trailer my thing is
flipped so uni it's not bias we show
good and bad reviews right
beautiful
in fact abe i left my own review here
bring that out yeah i left a review
and i wanted to frame it because
[Laughter]
[Music]
just because i as a tech i'm a youtuber
and i take technology very seriously
and so i really thought it was important
to
commemorate commemorate
this review
using triller has been one of the worst
experiences of my life by ethan k one
star
i would rather get a colonoscopy from a
chain link fence
over having to use this software one
more time
because it's like buggy and glitchy and
i don't want to support ryan kavanaugh
either
i would rather get e coli from a drip
from a dripping dirty sanchez on a
scorching day in death valley
instead of trying to operate this tick
tock knockoff ever again
[Music]
i would rather listen to david dobrik's
luciferian demon laughter play on loop
as my ears bleed in some sort of hellish
vlog night terror i can't wake up from
is
instead of logging into the trailer
also i heard that ryan ryan cavanaugh
was involved in a ponzi scheme according
to his former business partner allegedly
one star out and so we framed this and i
think we're just gonna
do brick
[Applause]
so
that's my trailer and we'll we'll dress
that up
it's like the app
yeah put it on the side i think what we
need to do is that's still in the shot
yeah that's good thank you
we just need to get like i want to get
like a neon sign
and it can say like triller one star
review
one star review and just dress it up so
it's more clear what it is right
but yeah that's my one star review of
triller and um if you guys and obviously
it's your freedom it's you you have free
speech to share your thoughts on trailer
as i did on the podcast when they're
suing me for
i was just sharing my free speech
that's triller ryan cavanaugh
cavanaugh's trailer
trailer my thing's flipped
oh bro that ain't the only thing getting
flipped
actually um
ryan kavanaugh's trying to be dana white
here on on
twitter
this is the event of the year he's
hyping his next fight with
everyone can't wait to watch oscar de la
hoya how old is oscar de la hoya i think
he's in his 50s
can you put on a real fight dude
everyone's super hyped for the event of
the year 50 year old oscar de la hoya
verse
48 verse bobby
who's he fighting he's he's 48. who's
oscar fighting here let's watch this
he's gonna sue me he's like you will
show my commercial without permission
i'm suing you
who's he fighting teo
teo
everyone can't wait to watch oscar de la
hoya
was the last time oscar de la hoya even
fought
like 20 years
the event of the century
anyway brian cavanaugh got 20 likes on
this
so
he's huge he's making waves this guy
it's crazy how he bankrupt uh his
previous company relativity too
his investors should know about that if
they
anyway
after reading the variety article and
looking into very clearly a one star app
trailer
and listening to the hd podcast today i
decided to pay your twitter a visit
after deep dive here i can safely say
your twitter is a one star also
[Music]
someone said how can i get on that ponzi
scheme good question oh god
you you know you might want to get
connected with people like ricegum
and some people in the faze clan could
be good partners for ryan cavanaugh yeah
yeah so this is face blanks
this guy does say he sees the
resemblance to harvey weinstein oh
interesting
yeah look at here there's the image of
the uh ryan cavanaugh accused by ex part
of running a ponzi scheme yeah that's
him same guy
so i'm gonna be reading and listen next
week if we want to do
i'm just curiou i'm following triller
carefully because i care about
technology
and so i'll be reading reviews
um
checking in on the reviews continuously
just to see
just to keep my pulse on the technology
i like to keep my pulse on on
on the happenings in the tech world as a
youtuber yeah
trailer my thing's flipped
i can't wait to tell you guys about the
details though yeah he's still suing me
it sucks
but it's such a flip for it's even more
frivolous than matt haas like when i
read their actual complaint and and it's
it's so bad that i'm almost i don't see
how it's even possible that not only
will we win on a file to uh just a
motion dismiss but i feel like they're
definitely gonna be paying our lawyer
fees too
i hope well don't well don't jinx it
clarence clean water over here
don't
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] with it man
i didn't say it right
just just so accountable i don't even
say it right just just trust me please
no
well i don't want to get too confident
but you know because everything's
possible in litigation you know that's
one of the things that the lawyers tell
you about
i'm feeling very
good about my case at least i don't know
how the judge can go but i feel great
about the case i can say that you know
so
super stoked on oscar de la hoya fight
of the century
and hopefully it lasts more than uh 30
seconds like their last big headline
fight
maybe even less perhaps
um you want to go down tick tock rabbit
hole
we got a lot of great tick tocks we can
end on this
okay
oh but before i do that actually i want
to get your take on this is this show
out the sexy beast because it looks kind
of [ __ ] awesome
i actually
i'm super interested in the show
yeah because i love reality show you
know me i want to get married i want to
have babies tell me before i'm like 26.
health insurance
welcome to the strangest blind date ever
the makeup is super good
how are you doing could you fall in love
with someone based on personality alone
what is your ideal woman
it's vendor mccarran
first personality second you're the best
looking devil i've ever seen this is
really weird right now
would you count this as a weird
experience for you
are you interested in the seal
i'm definitely gonna watch this
super interested in this so weird
but so what if i pick you and i'm not
what you expect
so you
you pick your sexy beast and then you
see if they're attractive i guess don't
but the thing is they're all attractive
yeah they're all
that's the part
exactly that's the part that kind of
ruins it for me there's no there's no
one that looks like me on that show
that's what i thought she looks like i'm
literally just like in love with the
moment oh
[Music]
time has come this is gonna be really
tough for me i can't choose both of you
i've made my decision my sexy beast is
so
there's interspecies relationships bro i
am so watching this
july 21st oh it's not out yet okay
oh i'm so i think the show's gonna be a
mega hit
it's just so weird that you have to
watch it
but the makeup is so good it is really
good yeah that's like a huge budget and
they gotta do it every episode yeah
yeah but they're all super attractive
based on what i saw there's no one i'm
to come
half big sound bite i'm going to come
but i like um
there's nobody with like birth defects
or anything
or like fire victims or something that'd
be interesting if there's people with
like burns
love conquers all
that would be that's the test i don't
want to see some hot sexy model i'm
going to see a dude it's like an extreme
version of a hijab
yeah like you're supposed to judge a
woman based on her yeah
oh
when do you get to if you're dating a
girl a woman in a high job when do you
get to see her face like without it you
mean yeah
once
i believe like i'm gonna get yelled at
because
everyone says different things but it's
supposed to be after you guys are
married
oh you can see your face till after
you're married i'm yeah i'm not yo they
take it to the next level like
christians are like virginity but
they're like you can't even see your
face i've always wondered about that
i've kind of asked selena because lena's
more traditional her family like what if
i don't know what if you're not
you get married and then you take it off
you're like oh yeah very
i mean it's more common that you just
don't show hair but
you know some like in saudi arabia or
something they only show their eyes so
wow that's hardcore man
[Music]
that's a real romantic romantic
no seriously because it's all about love
it's not about the physical appearance
i'm not being ironic how dare you
it gets beautiful
oftentimes an arranged marriage
uh no not always i mean
in like saudi arabia i mean saudi arabia
yeah probably probably but like yeah
women just got the right to drive a few
years ago so
this one was on my home page
and i'll just tell you before we watch
it that i went to his page
he is not a comedian
none of his videos have a lot of views
this is a 100 serious tick tock
not a joke
i kind of like the way this looks what
do you guys think the biggest question
is any girls out there want to sit on my
face
oh my god
exactly wrecked
it's amazing
uh it's a freaking amazing
you know
and i'm sure there are
sure there are
so
you know
yeah i mean i went to his channel i was
like this guy's a comedian obviously but
like no
oh this this must be the sit on facebook
i kind of like the way this looks yeah i
ended up getting a lot of views but if
you go back
his [ __ ] is getting like you know
nothing here in case you haven't noticed
sometimes i will give you deep [ __ ]
other times i will just be tossing the
[ __ ] around
interesting okay
fantastic
what are baby cars afraid of at night
when they go to sleep
monster trucks under their bed
got him
um
i just love that oh this what's the
backstory in this one maybe is this your
guy the guy who wanders around in the
woods
i believe that it's cam's originals
yeah
[ __ ]
hey bonnie this is scott lion's friend
i can't wait to meet you
oh [ __ ]
whoa
what
is he on his way somewhere
hey bonnie this is scott russell's
friend
i can't wait to meet you
what is going on
well we have his account we can do a
little fair bit of investigating if i if
i can just make a note a cams for you
page is the greatest for you page you've
ever seen in your life
yeah i heard he's he's been
he's really like disciplined and what he
interacts with which is the key to
keeping it pure this is perfect
i mean here's our boy let's see what
he's up to
this is to anyone who tries to tell me
who to be with or not
anybody
i'm with a friend
somebody says she's used me no
i'm doing what she needs me to do
because i love her hell yeah
and also
don't need to be
negative about people
oh yeah since someone who they have not
met i met her
a year ago hell yeah all right
so this one ended up this one was just
so interesting this is why tick-tock is
great is because a video like this
small account 1.7 million views wow the
people can tell there's something
special about this video
special video
hey bonnie this is scott russell's
friend
i can't wait to meet you
that's you know that's a special video
yeah
these people just they there's a like a
cosmic
there's some kind of cosmic
uh
dan you are so [ __ ] loud with those
chips bro
put put down on the screen
are you even trying not to make as much
noise as possible people can hear in the
bag right they can hear the bag
oh please they can definitely because my
mic is muted and sort of oh is it let's
see can people hear the bag
did people hear the bag before i called
him out i want to know
get a get a straw poll up there can you
hear dad's chip gent dance chip bag i'm
like dad sorry dan
and in the meantime there's more
here we go
police department just back off
just hit me again trying to come
mass destruction through their nuclear
weapons they've made they're talking
about mass look at all the spit that
comes out of his mouth destruction you
see that
wait let me slow mo because there's like
a bunch of specks of spit
he goes i don't need your map
watch this
watch coming out here
you see that there's like a chunk in
there
you see the chalk i saw it right here
look right here
we don't i do need you to wear a mask
bro when you're spit
when chunks are flying out of your mouth
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah
so 80
said they do not hear that okay bag 20
did though 20 are trolling
you wouldn't be able to hear it i was it
was very loud
you're five feet away from me
the microphone was muted
[Music]
there's a whole this guy's great too
love this guy
whoa whoa
so what's interesting about this guy
is that all of his videos are
very similar
his the whoa [ __ ] is kind of his thing
in which i dig
it's his thing which i think is very
cool
here
so
um this is where you guys bring them
whoa whoa whoa [ __ ] i'm on the other
side look look look i'm on the other
side convention center right here soon
goes that way i wonder if it's like a
there's another over there convention
center i'm on another side sorry i'm
trying
good i wonder if it's like a new trend
like the
white claw game wannabes
where it's like people try to have their
stick now the wobble [ __ ] guy yeah oh
look at the pretty boy face looking paw
looking paw dude whoa whoa whoa
damn oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] you at where the
[ __ ] are you at man
frank kavanagh i got a lineup for you
be about as interesting as your next
fight
yeah he's the well [ __ ] guy you could be
right about that either
should we get well [ __ ] guy on the phone
[Music]
him versus white claw game
no nobody would ever i wouldn't speak
white claw game and i would check
gabe to that never
how dare you gabe's an angel
yeah this guy's really interesting he
just
he grunts at people like that um as they
walk by super interesting
that's this whole channel
gangsta stalker hunter hernie who's his
name
he just growls at people as he walks by
it's pretty epic
here
oh no he got banned
oh
but why is this up oh cause we
downloaded it yeah we ripped it oh no
not grunker hunter
oh this guy's great captain cream this
is a pretty um
this is a great channel here either
you'll like this
pretty popular actually
it's pretty popular oh god what the
it's another creamer
no
you don't like the cream i hate the
creaming
look at this [ __ ]
i don't like it
how does he get such clean eye holes
just a little it's a little poke poke
you know it's like a nightmare yeah it
is kind of nightmarish for sure
captain cream
he looks like mr mesix
oh true
yes it's actually just a kid it's not
like
some
the good news is that it's not
some old weird
well it's not being done in a dungeon
yeah exactly it's not being done in a
dungeon for now
yet
world around wheat there's just there's
a lot of good stuff what can i tell you
guys we've been holding we've been
saving up here
yeah i mean
what the [ __ ]
yeah
no
no why is this one here i hate it i
don't want to see it do not like do not
like abort
don't like that one
hey my name is nick i just like to look
at girls here on tick tock and i really
like looking at the different
scenes that are on tick tock it's really
exciting to watch all these videos i
hope everyone has an excellent day and
thanks for checking out this video so
wait
this was one i think this was um was
this on my home page or years cam i
think this was on my home page i think
you sent it yeah so this was just on my
home page yeah
and i was like oh this is so good
this dude is just putting himself out
there
and he likes looking at the girls
it's a fantastic damn it's nick i'm i
just like to look at girls here on tick
tock
and i really like looking at the
different
scenes that are on tick tock it's really
exciting to watch all these videos
i hope that everyone has an excellent
day you just share thanks for checking
out this video
thanks for checking out
wait he just wish you a good day why you
got to hate on what an honest guy though
oh no his channel also got a raise oh
man wow all my best friends are going
under
[ __ ]
too creepy wait the account the name of
his account is i just like looking at
girls that was the name of his account
crazy that's probably what got him
oh no i'm sorry that's not the name of
it that was the name of the video
okay oh no that was the name i just like
looking at girl that is that is his
account name oh yeah [ __ ]
or it was rather
okay
fair enough
so is it uh
yay
time
[Music]
you know what i'm saying gila
fourth time
yes ma'am
anything else we want to talk about any
donations we want to read
anything you guys want me to address
james
anything james charles you want me to
follow up on before we go
please stop making comments on saudi
arabia that are so wrong oh i didn't say
they
blame me
they they did say
all respect you need to fact check
yourself i'm sorry by the way thank you
for the i mean
women say that he knows everything
he did say that people were listening i
think you need to check yourself if
you're if you're believing someone has
blonde hair and a bunch of tattoos as
your muslim leader our arab
representative oh i'm sorry yes but all
he said was that that overseas they just
got the right to drive women did like
what was it three years ago saudi arabia
two years ago so
i apologize if i'm not familiar with the
tournament
i'm gonna actually do i have to defend a
b a little bit here
um he did give a disclaimer
and your disclaimer proved true
immediately right i hope this doesn't
make you sound like a douche
what other thing that we say about saudi
arabia about the arranged marriages oh
you're talking about hijab one
conversation yo this is my one star
trailer review right here
trailer
one star
it's not showing me more so if you guys
have either anything else in saudi
arabia's the majority 65 plus of all
marriages are arranged marriages wow
that's a lot cooler
i don't know what that means hopefully
that means i got my back oh gotcha okay
what does it mean
we use it like hot we got you like like
but it means eat [ __ ]
i had a feeling it was
there's just something about the tone
james charles is no longer trending no
it breaks my heart
damn all right well guys it's friday
have a great great great great great
weekend
fourth of july weekend i mean my
goodness yeah
what a fantastic taking next week off
it doesn't add up
wait what did you say then we're taking
next week off we're taking them oh yeah
oh you're making a joke yeah or are we
because i know when he lives i'm trying
to i'm trying to manifest it oh i'm
making a joke
i need i do need like a week off for
real
uh later later in
this month um we actually will be taking
a break from after dark for two weeks
because ela will be out of town and
because we actually pre-recorded this
and she's already gone
this is a pre-recording this is a fake
live ila is already gone that's right so
don't [ __ ] i had no idea this was
going to happen
that's right we're actually we're
actually in the middle of a debate with
stephen crowder right now this is all
pre-recorded
let's just end it before i say anything
start that music where's the music
hit me with that music there it is
all right thanks for watching thanks for
watching everyone
we'll see you next friday
before the break yeah baby
we podcast now
you're watching
three three three three you're watching
h two three three three three you're
watching h two three three three three
you're watching h two three three three
three my drinks are made wild incest
honestly shredder was not barking off
raiders at the swing we'll do the real
raw ritual with more and e.t share a
laugh with the ringer see out loud jimmy
lee they said we wouldn't come back but
you we always do embrace from the ashes
like the phoenix on the flex back to two
[Music]